تنضم الينا الان من عمان لواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
بك معنا اعود في البدايه الى تصريحات
ودرجه اهميتها لا يمكن للقوات الاوكرانيه
ان تستعيد الاراضي التي خسرتها في هذا
العام دلالات هذا التصريح برايك
يعني هو وصف الواقع ولكن هو تحدث
بنصف الحقيقه لانه للجانب الروسي يستطيع
ان يحقق اهدافه السياسيه التي وضعها
الكرملين ولا الجانب الاوكراني يستطيع
استعاده ما فقده وهذا تحدثنا به كثيرا
وتحدث به العديد من المحللين ولكنه الان
جاء على لسان مسؤول وليس على لسان محلل او
خبير فاعطاه هذا البعد التقييمي الدقيق
لماذا لانه الاهداف اكبر من الوسائل
المتاحه الان
استعاده على سبيل المثال افتراضيا استعاده
دومباس جابولوجيا خرسون مع استثناء القرن
لن يتحقق دون وجود ليس اقل من ثلاث الى
اربع فرق مدرعه اي بمعنى ما يقارب الف
دبابه ماذا وصل اقل من 30 دبابه كيف يمكن
ان تحقق لا يمكن اذا دعني اقول الاهداف
اكبر من الامكانات واكبر وسائل المتاحه
بالحديث عن الامكانات ما تقييمك لهذه
الخطوه من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بزياده
الذخائر
واضافه خط تصنيع جديد
يا سيدي الحرب مكلفه جدا على الجانبين
والكل يعاني من نقص الذقائر الجيش الروسي
يستخدم
صواريخ اس 300 وهي صواريخ ارض جو يستخدمها
منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر بدور صواريخ ارض
ارض وبالتالي هناك نقص وهذه الحرب لن
تنتهي في عام 2023 واذا كان هناك حسم مع
توفر الامكانات لاحد الطرفين وهي بعيده
فبالتالي قد تكون في العام القادم او قد
يكون هناك حل سلمي الان هذا المعدل
الاستهلاك العالي والافراط في الاستقدام
واستخدام العقيد القتاليه الشرقيه اللي هو
تسطيح الارض من خلال القصف الناري وجعل
سياسه الارض المحلول المحروقه تحتاج الى
مستودعات والى نظام امداد له بدايه وليس
له نهايه لهذا السبب يجب ان يزيد الانتاج
لا بل قد يضطر الى ان يحول الشراء الشركات
الصناعيه ذات الانتاج للاستخدام المزدوج
ان تساهم في رفض المعركه شكرا جزيلا لك من
عمان لواء فايز الدويل الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي